l'association de lutte contre la
maltraitance des animaux l214 a frappé
une nouvelle fois un infiltré des 214
dénonce de nouvelles maltraitance
animale dans un abattoir en diffusant
plusieurs vidéos d'une violence
insoutenable tourné en caméra cachée au
sein même d'un l'abattoir bigard en
saône-et-loire des bovins conscience
suspendu par l'équipe des vaches en
gestation sur le point d'être tué
ils vont plus se procurer de telles
images c'est grâce à un homme thomas
saïdi nombre d'associations qui a réussi
à sa fixe nord se présentant comme
contrôleur en abattoir durant quatre
mois il a récolté des images et des
preuves de maltraitance pour dénoncer
les nombreuses infractions à la
réglementation de cet établissement il a
on peut voir la famille qui est l'un des
13 ans leurs yeux
la troisième mi temps ce soir thomas
salis était avec nous il va nous
raconter son immersion exceptionnel au
coeur de cet abattoir
merci en tout cas thomas d'être avec
nous ou thomas militants l214 et
enquêteurs donc vous avez un filtre est
donc le milieu des abattoirs comment
vous avez fait pour avoir ce job ça va
déjà merci beaucoup de mes recevoir la
parole donc pour intégrer cet abattoir
donc j'ai postulé à une offre qui était
sur pôle emploi pour travailler au sein
des services vétérinaires de l'abattoir
bigard de cuiseaux et j'ai envoyé un cv
avec un baccalauréat et trois
expériences en industrie qui n'avait
rien à voir avec ce type de poste
d'accord j'ai rapidement eu un entretien
avec le vétérinaire officiel de
l'abattoir est en fait c'est vite devenu
présentation de postes j'ai vite compris
qu'ils avaient y avait pas d'autre
candidat en fait élever ta mère me l'a
plus jamais d'accord vous étiez le seul
candidat gt gt le seul qu'on est le seul
candidat d'accord mon team hm on n'a pas
vraiment eu d'entretien il me montrait
la chaîne d'abattage et l'a montré à mon
futur poste et à la fin il m'a demandé
alors à ce que tu as peur du couteau est
ce que tu as peur du sang est en fait là
j'ai compris que c'était un des seuls
critères de d'embûches pour pouvoir
intégrer les services vétérinaires de
l'abattoir d'accord alors on va voir
première image
c'est une image qui a énormément fait
parler cette vidéo où l'on découvre que
le sont des veaux morts est prélevée
dans l'institut dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
regardez ça
avant d'être jetés dans les poubelles il
ya une personne qui en charge de
récupérer de prélever le sang de ces
foetus confère du cerveau le prélèvement
de sang effet sur tous types de foetus
mais principalement sur les petites
prête à naître puisque c'est là qu'on
trouve la plus grosse quantité de sang à
partir du sang ponctionnés sur les
foetus un opérateur de l'abattoir va
extraire du sérum qui sera
commercialisée par serra france et qui
sera vendu aux industries
pharmaceutiques pour faire de la culture
cellulaire vous avez vu vous
vous avez une caméra sur vous à chaque
fois quand même caméra cachée comme ça
vous étiez en immersion comment s'est
passé alors je peux pas vous donner les
détails techniques pour réaliser ces
images me rassure bien sûr mais c'est
vous qui avez tout filmé c'est moi qui
étais aussi mis d'accord alors quand
vous voyez ça est-ce qu'il y en a qui se
disent pas ce que je vous dit où on va
on se dit tous ici à thomas il ya des
gens aussi on va avoir d'autres images
et des gens qui disent aussi c'est des
milliers d'emplois et
ccc aussi voilà c'est ça ça va mettre
beaucoup de gens au chômage si elle
passe cette industrie voiliers de
travail par voilà c'est vrai que voilà
je vous dis toujours je vous dis tout ce
que je vois sur les réseaux sociaux il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont bien sûr
très choqué la plupart par ces images il
y en a aussi qui disent ah qu'est ce que
vous dites à ces gens là non mais
évidemment que c'est on va pas aller on
va pas fermer les abattoirs parce que
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens de
fermer les abattoirs en revanche faire
un coup de balai nettoyer essayer de le
faire parce que aidé à battre de façon à
ce que les animaux souffrent le moins
possible est bon et le moins de 2 de
latence est ce que conscience et la loi
voilà ce qui est ce qui est normalement
la loi moi ce qui me sidère c'est bon je
vois monsieur que vous avez envoyé un cv
avec aucune qualification quand vous
demande rien ce n'est ce que vous avez
peur du sang et d'un couteau et
qu'ensuite on vous jette là dedans en
vous disant en gros démerde toi c'est ça
qui est incroyable simple de ça donc je
n'avais pas de pas de diplôme pas
d'expérience et j'ai eu aucune formation
donc en fait j'ai et on a donné des
explications sur le tas à des
informations contradictoires et s a eu
des conséquences je pense assez grave à
la fois sur le point de vue sanitaire et
sur le bien-être animal par exemple on
me disait quand tu trouves des secours
sur la carcasse a battu tu dois les
enlever même si tout reste quelques-unes
ses pattes arriver quelqu'un derrière va
s'en charger d'autres me disais non non
il faut qu'il faut que les enlève les
que tu sortes la carcasse mais en fait
les foulures c'est entre l'herbe fraîche
la matière fécale est resté combien de
temps je suis resté quatre mois et donc
dans les fouilleurs en fait liée à la
bactérie escherichia coli est dangereuse
pour la santé humaine c'est extrêmement
grave et ça m'a jamais dit mais en fait
si si les consommateurs mangent cette
bactérie l'aï leopard ils peuvent mourir
ça c'est extrêmement dangereux on n'a
jamais informé de ça et c'est pareil
pour le bien-être animal en fait j'ai
marché dont je voudrais qu'on montre un
autre extrait bien sûr qu'il nous a
classé le sens celui où l'on découvre
l'abattage rituel
c'est une étape que vous avez pu
contrôler au bout d'une semaine après
avoir été embauché sarthe a fait donc
une semaine après vous étiez à s'auto
elle va même dans laquelle vous assistez
à l'égorgement des vaches sans
anesthésie regardez ces images sont c
est forte
elle mal rentrer dans une box c'est
entre deux de pillage cylindrique pour
faire entrer une vache dans le piège des
battages rituel il faut la forcer ils ne
rendent pas d'elle-même donc on lui met
des coups de bâton des coûts de piles
électriques parfois même souvent j'ai
même déjà vu une personne met des coups
de bâton exprimant dans le visionnage
pour qu'elle sorte les têtes
dans le cadre de l'abattage rituel
lorsqu'il ya des signes évocateurs de
leur prise de conscience des opérateurs
de l'abattoir sont sensés et produire
d'urgence l'animal pour lui éviter des
souffrances inutiles en quatre mois dans
cet abattoir pendant toute ma mission je
n'ai jamais assisté les celle de
tourisme d'urgence
oui bah tu veux
vraiment vraiment horrible c'est que
c'est que normalement effectivement il
ya des gars des normes pour que les
animaux soient soient soient abattus ce
qui est déjà horrible mais bon c'est
comme ça mais je crois et je pense que
thomas peux confirmer c'est que il ya je
crois moins de 5% des abattoirs qui sont
contrôlés pour voir si justement les
animaux sont tués dans des dents dans
les normes dans les conditions au moins
2 5% c'est vous laisse imaginer combien
il ya des battoirs en france qui à mon
avis pratiquer ce genre de pratiques est
ce que c'est vrai ce que je dis oui tout
à fait merci gilles pourquoi il faut
former les abattoirs moi je réponds oui
et valérie non les abattoirs dans
l'évangile et tu vas être comblé mais
j'assume j'ai envie arrête à subir à
rennes par est d'être démago comme ça
elle arrive à l'aller rilliard est
insupportable
excuse moi jle mais la chute est
insupportable en s'imposant tranquille
ici tu poses ton cul sur la chaise était
content de travailler pense à dia plein
de gens qui ont besoin de travailler
arrête de dire des conneries mais c'est
vrai qu'il arrête ça m'énerve ça me rend
fou ça le mec il est tranquille ici tu
es au chaud tu poses ton coup de chance
dames et un salaire tous les mois tu vas
mettre des milliers de gens au chômage
arrête un peu près la moitié de ces gens
là ces redditions limites en dépression
ça aussi
arrêter les conneries mais milliers de
restaurateurs qui cherchent des serveurs
mais
s'ils avaient le choix entre autres
choses il ne ferait désolé pour la
plupart ce que vous dites la moitié sont
des pressions donc c'est à dire que la
moitié monsieur qui sont des purs s'ils
avaient le choix qu'ils avaient le choix
de faire autre chose il l'aurait fait
donc ils n'ont pas le choix et quand
gilles verdez tu dis il faut fermer tous
les abattoirs excuse moi j y si l'on
étudié magot j depuis le maire d' excuse
moi tu te rends pas compte qu'il ya des
mecs qui vont se retrouver au chômage du
jour au lendemain alors arrête tes
conneries arrête un peu de vouloir
d'être démago surtout pense un peu à
voir aussi engagé pour gagner contrôle
bah oui oui jusqu'à dire à jérémie c'en
est tout à fait hélas sociale soit 214
il faut un travail magnifique je
travaille pour ça parce qu'ils montrent
des choses et il montre qu' il ya des
gars d il ya parfois il ya des choses
qui vont pas et ça c'est important de
mauvaises pour ça qu'on le montre ce
soir on va on aurait pu ne pas faire le
sujet mais quand tu dis il faut fermer
les abattoirs d'une connerie basilan je
peux finir oui bah oui parce que en fait
monsieur de normandie le ministre de
l'agriculture il a fait des tas de plan
je les ai tous regarder les plans
abattoirs ça ne fonctionne pas depuis
2020 il ya six abattoirs qui ont été
fermés quatre ont pu rouvrir rien ne
change donc si vous voulez continuer
cyril avoir des images comme ça et ils
ne feront rien n'est arrêté
mais tu penses o'toole à tous les autres
mois est au chômage tu vas faire quoi
après venir sur le plateau et tu vas
dire bah oui bah ils ont entraîné est
toujours là tu es toujours en train de
défendre ceux qui sont sur deux passions
la race d'hérens les animaux cédés on
veut tout défendre les animaux mais se
défendent aussi les humains mais
plusieurs mois des conneries à 12h mar
est de fermer les choses par étapes il
ya plein de gens qui sont au chômage ya
plein de gens qui travaillent tu te
rends compte ou pas d'astuce tryba
briller les images racontent que c'est
que l'industrie de la viande aux
chansons non pas mettre ces centaines et
des centaines de milliers de gens au
chômage arrête un peu mais je dis des
conneries excuse moi ça me rend fou moi
c'est les mecs comme toi excuse moi ça
me rend fou donc vous étiez dehors de la
société excuse moi j'irai de poser à
côté de la plaque à chaque fois tu veux
faire plaisir à tout le monde tu veux
faire plaisir aux animaux tu veux faire
plaisir à tout le monde dit pas de
connerie il faut il ya ni attiyah dia
d'eyadema venir dire d'iliad et malia
dès qu'il ya des malveillances et des
choses qui sont mal faites et alors il
faut essayer de les régler mais tu vas
pas mettre des millions sur hp tu as pas
arrêter l'industrie de la viande tous
les bouchers boîte au chômage au cynisme
et on va fermer toutes les boucheries et
les aliens amar est à peu près cela bord
pense d'abord un petit peu aux humains
les violences d'un géraldine une fatigue
d'abord macho que vous faites un travail
incroyable sur wii c'est pour ça qu'on
les a reçus de ce soir c'est bien
pensable et justement ça dénonce les
abattoirs low cost absolument cruel
indigné que ça se corse c'est pas
loquace et miquelon salle dit c'est pas
les noms
ça sort du groupe bigard donc le groupe
bigard ccam le premier groupe ses paris
de viande
bovine en toi aussi mettre tous les gens
du groupe bigard au chômage on ne peut
pas dire on va pas le côté picard demain
je suis désolé arrivée nord pour pas
cher parce que les gens veulent manger
de la viande pas cher et donc les gens
achètent de la viande casher parce
qu'ils ont des problèmes aussi de
pouvoir d'achat ils veulent pouvoir de
la mls à forbach oui on a besoin on a
besoin d'en savoir moi j'aimerais faire
deux minutes après je joue avec mon
estomac j'adore ça et je paye vegan
parce que je veux pas me c'est parce
qu'il aime en octobre ait au moins tout
soit bien fait comment on fait justement
comment comment fait vous monsieur vous
pensé pour réguler sa et pour qu'ils
abattent war ben clean le plus clean
possible et le plus respectueux de
l'animal à les contrôler déjà il ya des
choses jamais revenir sur le débat sur
le sol les êtres humains moi j'ai
beaucoup de compassion pour les employés
des abattoirs important de le dire voilà
beaucoup travaillé avec eux il ya
énormément d judiciaire finirait bien
sûr il ya beaucoup d'immigrés que
personne aussi que son souffrance c'est
un travail qui est répétitif et ils sont
en adobe douleur il s'accélère
d'exemplaires musculaire oui on
travaille d'entendre avec du son des
odeurs de pure joie des mois serait
aujourd'hui vous dire comment mais il
disait tout
disparaît donc ce qu'il faut ça c'est
qu'ils doivent pas faire autre chose
bien sûr qu'ils ont besoin de vivre sur
mais la ccir dévolu donc ça prend du
temps ça va pas se faire en un jour mais
peut être sur plusieurs générations mais
il ya des métiers disparaissent d'autres
qui apparaissent donc sur du long terme
c'est totalement faisable donc la
question n'est pas de savoir si si si on
va perdre des emplois c'est d'abord de
dire est-ce que c'est légitime encore en
france d'avoir ce genre d'image
d'avion moi j'ai parlé aux vétérinaires
de l'abattoir et il m'a dit clairement
peu importe la méthode d'abattage les
animaux souffrent pour l'abattage
traditionnel l'abattage rituel est à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas de
solution miracle en fait en france moi
tu te crois bien que le 5 millions
d'animaux chaque jour donc si les
français veulent continuer à consommer
autant de viande on pourra tout y aura
toujours de la souffrance elles auraient
toujours qu'il faut réduire la
consommation de riz de viande a baissé
d'après vous dans les apps dans les
abattoirs on descend de la cadence et
donc on soit un peu plus exactement si
on veut respecter l'être humain à
l'animal la moins des chasses à
commencer par réduire tout à fait
parvenir la consommation alors
idéalement personnellement je
préférerais qu'on arrête mais si on peut
déjà commencer par réduire ses gains
améliorer les conditions
parce qu'il ya des gens qui bossent de
l'avion qui est pas trop j'ai
effectivement tout le monde voudrait
bord de l'avion qui est parfaitement iv
dans les prés experts mais c'est la
levée le kilo de boeuf il doit être fait
pas il est deux fois au trophée
jack-adams le marché donc c'est un vrai
problème effectivement moi j'ai tout le
monde est content est grosse des animaux
on va pas se mentir on voit pas tout
mais j'ose dire non à ce qui va se
passer si vous fermez les abattoirs
comme vous dis moi oui ils perdaient
cela elle parce que la mauvaise idée
excusez moi je vous adore en plus agile
vous le savez en dehors de ça mais ça
c'est la plus mauvaise idée en effet on
est pas du tout là il va vendre aux
étrangers on est à l'étranger à
l'étranger vont pas fermer l'abattoir
avec vous du côté de la plaque en fait
question voulez vous de bouc en fait je
vous le dis et je trouve que l 214 ils
font un super travail tristement pour
montrer ça ça il faut le montrer au
gouvernement qu'il essaie de faire des
choses qu'ils essaient d'améliorer tout
ça mais là dire fermer des abattoirs
fermer les sociétés et les délais parce
que derrière c'est qu'on va fermer les
boucheries on va fermer
n'importe quoi mais oui mais c'est
n'importe quoi eh ben il serait quoi
vous savez quoi on verra quand vous
aurez des millions personnes au chômage
on verra ce que vous ferez vous allez
dire aussi bas c'est pas bien mais on a
des milliers de mélomanes dépend de nous
tout dépend de nous tous dépend de notre
consommation si un certain nombre de
kilos de viande race à sortir par jour
suite à fait normal que les animaux faut
qu'on les presse beaucoup plus qu'un
animal il apparut nourrir donc forcément
y ce cadre nos qu'on doit ma chambre de
lui donner des coups c'est cette cadence
là qu'est le problème et moi ces images
à vous lire je vous dire ça le problème
que tu as des films c'est que les mecs
les mecs ils vont pas manger moins de
viande non quoi qu'il arrive si ça peut
réduire mais ouais mais chez oui mais il
faut le faire et donc ça me préparer je
deviens faire les changements des radars
faut le faire à l'échelle mondiale sinon
ça va se passer même en france non mais
on y aller non mais oui mais
les lâchetés ailleurs c'est ça
l'histoire la france par le leadership
est le modèle inculquer aussi de ce prêt
de pays il faut dire qu'un pays commence
la france et sos par mon leader mais
c'est si vrai ce que vous dites cyril
qu'il ya déjà on fait déjà appel à des
tables abattoirs étrangers lors des
conditions encore pire ne dénotera
social à ce que vous dites il ya une
chose qui a évolué c'est que autrefois
les vaches ne pensais pas du tout que ça
avait une psychologie etc etc maintenant
d'état d'études apparaissent qui
montrent que ce qu'on appelait les bêtes
de somme ça a des sentiments et sa
ressent profondément donc la loi va de
plus en plus obliger les abattoirs et il
faut évidemment répression et contrôler
mais effectivement pas six premiers des
emplois parce que ça ne changera
strictement canton tant qu'on n'aura pas
de vrais inspection vétérinaire parce
que ce qu'on voit là où il ya quand même
une trentaine de personnes pour tout le
territoire qui sont qui font d
inspection vétérinaire qui n'en sont pas
réellement parce qu'évidemment et ils
ont qu'ils peuvent pas être partout on
aura toujours ce genre malheureusement
d'image d'isolement les inspecteurs
central 1 % des élevages chaque année
des verrines et c'est un problème ça
c'est un problème l214 a aussi tourné
une vidéo pour dénoncer le gavage des
oies et on voit que les conditions de
bien-être des animaux sont loin d'être
optimales pour le cas chaque année en
france 1 million d'oiseaux meurent en
cours de gavage
à l'âge de trois mois alors qu'un canard
pourrait vivre jusqu'à 20 ans les
canards sont sentis des cages et chargés
dans des caisses de transport pour être
conduits à l'abattoir ils seront
électrocuté seigner qui ait existé
ils seront mis en pièces leur foi
extirper de leur cadavre sera vendue
comme foie gras leur chair sera quant à
elle vendue sous l'appellation magret ou
confits pendant le chargement leur
surpoids et leur stress seront bien
visibles leur respiration et pénible et
accélérer
alors oui c'est vrai que ces images ces
machines
moi je suis désolé mais je suis d'accord
avec jim stark à une forme d'hypocrisie
en fait tout le monde se dit voilà c'est
donc tout un nom alors je pense qu'il
faut respecter l'humain évidemment pas
mettre ces gens n'ont pas mettre les
gens en difficulté c'est pas parce qu'il
ya des gens qui travaillent qu'il faut
pas agir tout le monde en train de
rechercher des yeux en regardant les
images tous ont bien mangé un steak on
va s'arrêter 60 ans voilà je pense qu'il
faut éduquer les gens moi même en vrai
j'ai arrêté de manger de la viande c'est
pas une vanne parce qu'en voyant ces
images je trouve ça dégueulasse et je
pense qu'il faut dire aux gens qu'on n'a
pas besoin de manger de la viande
pourrie oui c'est pas une non de tuer
les années on va mais quand tu dis ça
quand tu dis ça va je vais te dire qu'il
faut de la liste à quand une fois que tu
as dis ça veut dire comment tu fais pas
grand tu fais parce que tu vas te
retrouver avec des sociétés qui vont
faire beaucoup moins de béziers mission
faire beaucoup monde vont pouvoir
embaucher les gens vont toujours servir
non mais non ne crions à 12 emplois non
non non
non mais je suis d'accord mais surtout
celui-là militants pensent en fait vous
êtes les ayatollahs non megan abattoirs
je sais pas si c'est possible mais je
pense que c'est possible voilà en fait
clean il n'y a pas de hiérarchie dans la
souffrance
alors moi je pour moi je suis sentie
species comme toi je considère que
malgré tout l'insecte ou la crevette
qu'a mangé hier matthieu delormeau elle
est en dessous de ramadan c'est la parle
de vaches on parle de vaches et doit la
voir je sais que c'est cruel mais je
pense qu'il ya des filières quand même
qu'ils doivent tuer ces animaux de
manière moins cruel que ce qu'on a vu le
monsieur est ce que ça existe des
abattoirs plus respectueux race et
hormis du droit normal c'est une bonne
question ça c'est intéressant parce que
moi souvent quand je parle des enquêtes
on me dit non mais ça c'est un cas à
part non je suis normal mais voilà on me
dit souvent ça c'est un abattoir c'est
pas comme ça dans les autres abattoirs
là on parle quand même donc je vais le
répéter du d'un batteur du groupe
billard qui le premier groupe industriel
de viande et oui on aura créé beaucoup
d'emplois le groupe bien la tant
attendue car ils ont un peu disons
beaucoup d'argent et en plus de ça le
préfet de saône et loire va visiter
l'abattoir pendant que j'étais là bas il
a dit que c'est un abattoir qui était
extrêmement moderne il était champion
bon là ce qu'on voit c'est un abattoir
qui est considéré comme mort au top du
top et donc il y aura toujours de la
suze compte de la souffrance nous tue 3
5 millions d'amis d'un niveau chaque
jour donc forcément ça crée des
conditions comme ça donc voilà ma
connaissance non j'ai jamais vu
d'abattoirs clymène qui respecte les
animaux c'est incompatible même les
petits bouchers quartier tout ça ils
n'ont pas des filières plus clean selon
m cet abattoir monde avait menti et
s'est tué 88 il ya eu des vidéos comme
label rouge il ya eu des vidéos comme ça
sur les abattoirs label rouge arrondi
oui moi je réduis mon cosma consommation
de viande et en plus je mange que du
billet ou label rouge c'est exactement
la même chose est ici dans le public
pareil pour nous la moitié des personnes
n'ont pas regardé ces images on ne peut
pas si on cautionne pas si on regarde
pas on cautionne pas on peut pas rejeter
ces images c'est la viande au final
qu'il faut rejeter on peut pas avoir
envie de vomir
regardez avoir une envie de manger
c'est pas possible
mais pour mes amis pourquoi t'as pas
regarder mais je n'ai pas vraiment
surprise ce soir film d'horreur c'est la
réalité tous les jours je suis là mais
je voulais vous filmer mais
une fois qu'ils sont il faut être
honnête terme et les abattoirs s'éteint
c'est un hôtel le vergeur chance alors
mon nom là où je vous rejoins yens le
guen député jean glavany qui a quelqu'un
de quelques années a fait passer une loi
votée noah face à vous reconnaître que
l'animal n'est pas un objet mais qu'un
animal est un être humain et souffre
comme un hymne à la nature est tous
d'accord ne faut pas fermer les
abattoirs il faut alors augmenter même
très des bouleaux augmenter les
contrôles pour que les animaux puissent
souffrir le moins possible lorsqu'ils
vont aller à l'abattoir c'est ça la
réalité se situe à vous faire là les
conditions sont horribles je pense que
les moyens effectivement de lezennes de
l'es2 les étourdir de leur donner
peut-être quelque chose pour qu'ils
aient pas conscience j'en sais rien
comme comme on pourrait le faire pour
des bons pour des humains l'hôpital
quand ils sont pas bien de limiter la
souffrance facture en oeuvre depuis des
années sont ils bougent pas
et
d'y remédier elle fait mach hitech de la
viande de chat mais le nombre de gens
que ça allait mettre au chômage
ça d'abord les avait prévenus mal oui
après les conséquences sociopolitiques
de géra évidemment la société vol il ya
des paires l'emploi des apparitions
évidemment si on fait un peu tout de
suite ça va être class america pour les
colonies mais il faut le faire et pas
pour l'économie moi je pense je sens qu
racing à cette génération là une
question si moi je pense au cas par cas
je pense à tous ces gens vous n'en avez
besoin d'épargner un instant j ai dit
vous avez passé quatre mois dans cet
abattoir vous êtes fait certainement des
potes avaient eu des gens qui
travaillent là bas et qui peuvent pas
travailler ailleurs et c'est leur gagne
pain ils sont là heureusement qu'ils
puissent pas qu'ils peuvent travailler
là bas comme encore avoir un emploi sont
pas loin de ses recettes travail
pourquoi ils sont heureux de faire ce
travail mais c'est justement ça sert pas
et ne font pas ce qu'ils peuvent pas
faire autre chose donc ya pas de travail
ailleurs donc ils sont obligés de faire
ça et sont obligés de travailler là bas
pour pouvoir vivre les pouvoir subvenir
aux besoins de leur fallut donc
forcément c'est qu'aujourd'hui moi j'ai
pas envie de voir des milliers de
personnes dans la rue parce que
aujourd'hui on a fermé des abattoirs où
aujourd'hui il ya une société qui est en
dépôt de bilan et qui faisait écho kae
kb qui avait des milliers d'emplois qui
créé des milliers d'emplois c'est le
seul truc donc il faut trouver le bon le
juste compromis tout évolue aujourd'hui
je crée des emplois pour éventuellement
avoir plus de contacts répétés et 6 à la
tuque votre avis
contrôleur depuis des années il y en a
jamais plus malgré tout les plans et
cyril moine ya quelque chose qui me gêne
quand même c'est que là vous établissez
clairement et je comprends tout à fait
une hiérarchie entre le chômage oui et
la maltraitance animale or vous dites je
préfère la maltraitance animale du tout
ce que tu dis toi toi tu dis en fait tu
veux faire plaisir à tout le monde moi
tu vas voir un mec tu as si demain on va
avoir un mec de chez bigard qui va venir
ici que je veux dire je me suis retrouvé
au chômage à cause de gilles verdez
trois ans voilà j'ai trois enfants il va
dire à pascal admis si nécessaire alors
quelle bande de cons il ya mais arrête
gilbert des
vieux tu dois penser pour moi tu dois
penser d'abord à lui maintenant bien sûr
c'est aux animaux cie aussi là oui il
faut penser d'abord à l'humain quand tu
vas avoir un mec qui va se retrouver à
la rue avec une famille parce que gilles
verdez qui a dit il faut pas manger de
cette viande est bien ce qu il ya gilles
verdez khadir faut voir mais tous les
abattoirs est bon d'avoir situe ballet
des aimants vers à berlin il viendra
chez toi avec sa famille on verra si tu
craques et quand on laisse des
médicaments la recherche des médicaments
sur les rats ou enfin ça c'est la plaine
où pas moins ambitieux je suis très
contente contraint des médicaments pour
les humains pardon
l'animal c'est vrai que ça c'est des
images on peut manger rien et je crois
que je retrouvais 200 canadiens sauf un
travail fabuleux l'instructeur ce que
dit mathieu la solution de mathieu que
le gouvernement essaie de trouver des
solutions pour avoir plus d'emplois et
essayer de faire plus de contrôles
plutôt que de dire comme toi faut fermer
tous les abattoirs il faut arrêter de
manger de la viande je vous le dis
arrêtez de dire histoire et que de
manger la viande parce que les mecs ça
c'est si l'utopie et plus
les gens ne sont jamais là on a vécu
énormément réduit je préfère regarder on
essaie ça trouver des solutions plus
rapides pour les animaux plutôt de dire
ça dure encore visionner et les aliments
vont se retrouver comme ça il était
comme ça encore longtemps si regarde at
war mais changeront jamais mythos mars
et les fonds
j'estime que c'est très utopique
d'imaginer d'avoir des du du respect
pour l'asie de l'est et des animaux mais
c'est super en sens contraire 3.5 à 1
millions d'animaux par jour sans tuer
c'est clairement utopique d'imaginer un
monde où les animaux seraient bien tuer
le cinquième possible donc il ya d'abord
la question éthique qui se posent la
question économique pour moi elle vient
après d'abord la question noire à la
question éthique et l'accès et morale on
est tous d'accord et ce qui est ce qu'il
est nécessaire de tuer ces animaux là
concernant ces images à son bébé on voit
des vaches se faire égorger les vaches
mais sont elles voient les vaches
d'accord une fois les à 2h suspendu à
une patte la gorge tranchée et ça jamais
ça thomas réserve d'accord qu'elle n'a
jamais vraiment les armes pour défendre
mais j'avais raison pour vous dis
heureusement qu'elle 214 dégraisseur
parce qu'il joue dit voilà qui marque un
travail remarquable et c'est vrai que
mais on peut pas on peut pas passer du
tout au tout maintenant si on veut aller
vite giuly le niveau là on évolue il
faut aller tout si on veut aller vite et
qui est des solutions rapides il faut
trouver des solutions de compromis si
vous allez dans le tout l'un ou tout
l'autre ça ne se fera jamais sinon ça va
prendre des années les aliments vont
continuer à souffrir ça va pas qu'est
tout le monde je pense qu'il faut
toujours trouver un compromis et essayer
d'aller step by step mais là le problème
quand j'entends des gens comme que
gilbert et j'aime beaucoup quand
j'entends j'ai le dernier vous êtes sûr
et certain et je vous dis pour vous
parce que je défends votre combat et je
trouve que vous faites de votre combat
est complètement louable et il est il
est sain quand il perdait 10 fermé tous
les abattoirs qui est sûr et certain que
ça ferait jamais et que tu as tu vas
attendre des années et des années et que
les animaux ils vont continuer à
souffrir que les gens vont continuer à
manger de la viande et que tu vas rester
dans un statu quo comme ça pendant des
années alors voilà ça pour moi c'est
tout ce qu'il faut pas faire après
peut-être que chez moi qui me trompe et
je le congrès et je veux c'est très
possible 5 214 en est parfaitement
conscient qu'il faille aller étape par
étape s'est retournée pape alors
justement c'est pour ça qu'après cette
enquête on a lancé une pétition pour
demander l'interdiction de l'abattage
sans étourdissement g sur l'interdiction
de l'abattage on voit là des atrocités
vraiment vraiment difficile à regarder
les cd en édition classique fallait
signer cette pétition les axes sur
lesquels à bravo thomas non mais
le vrai scandale c'est qu'on découvre
ces images via l 214
session extraordinaire oui
mais je vous dis quand même
personnellement moi je suis végétarienne
depuis 25 ans donc j'ai économisé plus
de douze mille animaux clairement je
n'ai pas donné de ma vie un centime aux
boucheries n'empêche que je m'alimente
tous les jours donc sans doute que je
donne de l'argent à plein d'autres
industries voilà donc s'il vous plaît ne
dit pas juste parce qu'on aime les
animaux on va mettre tout le monde au
chômage parce que du coup sûr mange
différemment ce qu'on dit non au sein du
site internet et booster
facebook twitter tu fais quoi avec tous
les projets c'est parce qu'on dit on
n'est pas à partir de nos mères non mais
c'est passé par les volumes c'est ce
qu'a dit gilles et avec un peu de vous
manger de la viande mais oui
je suis pas que jamais dit que j'étais
végétarien je les dis
ça mais ça n'a rien à voir jeudi la
question s'est étonné moi je mange très
bien debout je voudrais dire at il
urgence à fermer les abattant
aujourd'hui oui il faut un moratoire
casse pas les couilles à vous je réponds
à votre question il faut fermer les yeux
et il faut faire un moratoire de
quelques mois sur la consommation durent
en général parce que les abattoirs ne
changeront jamais c'est utopique et la
première loi date de 1997 la loi de
surveillance aucun effet rien ne change
et comment vous sentez vous avez lu en
d2 les sépales pour le sait pas moins
divergents mais pas moi
rien hormis une école
saint bris dit qu exigent un moratoire
il faut tout fermé pendant plusieurs
mois
solution merci gilles châteaulin